all right let's get started here more
stunning details on Hunter Biden's China
cash hold now try to keep up with this
you got a fourth mysterious Biden family
member who's raking in Chinese cash to
the tune of seventy thousand dollars
House Republicans are trying to unpack a
three million dollar payment from a
Chinese energy firm now defunct it was
sent back in 2017 to an associate of
Hunter Biden and then a million dollars
of that was split three ways between
Hunter James and Haley Biden now the how
thoughtful because of course she's so
qualified to talk about international
business because she was a grammar
school counselor don't take it from a
hunter's legal team even confirming the
payments but says the whole thing is a
giant nothing burger the big question
remains what exactly was the Biden
family doing on behalf of China to
receive these payments house oversight
committee chair James Comer has an
answer
they were influence peddling they were
it looks like they were getting money
for some type of service now I don't
think Hunter Biden could provide the
type of service that would generate
millions and millions of dollars from
the Chinese Communist party but I
believe his father could so when they
say that Joe Biden wasn't involved we
don't know that we just know that Joe
Biden met with a lot of these people
that that ended up going in business
with hunter or or ended up paying Hunter
rather and the family and this is just
the beginning and a big surprise here uh
Biden wasn't too Keen about taking
questions today with the Irish Prime
Minister
thank you all
[Applause]
everybody
else
[Music]
no press conferences no meetings no
interviews except for the Daily Show uh
judge what do you think he's really
thinking about the revelations coming
out from these banknotes well first of
all I think that what he's thinking is
it the the more they dig and we finally
got those what was it 150 Financial
transactions at the treasury Department
uh had had flagged and they did not want
to give to the house oversight here uh
but that's going to give us more
information but let's let's just talk
about what what's going on here right
now you've got Hunter Biden James Biden
Hallie Biden and a fourth Biden whose
name we don't know sharing over a
million dollars after two months after
Joe Biden leaves the vice presidency in
2016. all right what did they do for
those Services now Hunter can't possibly
do anything thing for a million dollars
unless it's seed money but show me that
that money went somewhere to some
business no one can show anything Haley
Biden I mean my God what did she do she
was having sex after her husband died
with Hunter Biden and uploading
pornographic stuff on the internet she
gets what seventy thousand dollars the
fourth Biden gets a payout just the name
Biden without a first name we know ten
percent went to the big guy not just
from the emails but from Bob Alinsky and
what we also know is that the Hunter
says I hope you don't have to pay 50
percent for the family like I had to do
with pop because he was texting with his
daughter was he texting right with his
daughter but let me explain one thing
why did Joe Biden lie and say in the
first place he doesn't know anything
about his son's business overseas what's
the big deal to admit yeah my son does
business overseas why lie it's called
consciousness of guilt and now they get
51 Intelligence Officers to say that
laptop is Russian disinformation the the
Royal Horse at this point now and to end
up
to it Hunter Biden is now
Sue being violated
it's the laptop is his and everything in
it is literally circumstantial evidence
that will corroborate not just influence
peddling but what did you get the money
for we're dealing with a Chinese Energy
company that is run by someone in the
Chinese Communist party and by the way
final Point why did they allow a Chinese
spycraft to go over our intercontinental
ballistic missile sites and identify
where our planes were what direction
they're in not even bring it down and
then I find out today Kirby says well
the president hasn't spoke with Xi
Jinping you mean to tell me he hasn't
even complained that spycrafts are all
over our country
I hear you so the laptop is real even
Hunter uh admissions
the Belton Road program which is
Sinister program to circumvent our
influence around the world the CFC was
one of the main engines for that and
president vice president former
President Biden is supporting that and
the bit and the big question is what was
the skill what was the talent what was
the asset the Biden family was bringing
to the table Harold Ford
so there's a lot here I I don't know
other than what I've read this is not a
story I mean but you've been tracking it
for the last two years well you know I
read in newspapers and all and it's not
to minimize it by just legally and we
were talking a little bit about it off
air um and this is not to defend anyone
I would never do business I can't
imagine doing business with the Chinese
company or Chinese Energy company but
number one a vice president former Vice
President Biden or Joe Biden was not in
office during what we're talking some of
the things we're talking about here we
gotta we're asking questions about when
he was in office and Hunter would travel
with him when he was a VP but some of
this stuff he was not in office number
two I'm not going to question a yell
educated lawyer's ability to understand
issues like Hunter Biden is this is not
a defensive his uh of him as a his
personal appetites for life I I pray for
him I'm a Christian believe everybody
deserves Second Chances he must be a
smart guy if they thought that so Comer
Congressman Comer said why would they
pay him but he says I don't know that he
jumpsuit they only paid him because his
father was a former vice president now
that may be but then he went to say that
Vice President Biden was doing this I
don't know any of this oh I can look at
are the fact so he was not in office so
if he did do business with them it was
legal he has to deal with his conscience
but it's legal two uh the laptop in
terms of it being an admission it's
clearly his laptop he denied it and the
dad denied it in the debate she said 51
intelligence experts say this is classic
Russian disinformation that's kind of
crazy well Brian they were wrong I'm
trying to think they were wrong uh and I
don't look I'm not here to defend any of
this I'm just as we react to some of
this story The Hunter thing is laptop I
understand the legal strategy to say
that guy if you take care take something
to be repaired and they turn it over to
the police you too so what is it why
what made you did you have a legal
reason judge you know you just can't
unless there's a reason right unless you
a crime is about to be committed or
you're about to prevent yourself there's
no crime but could I just know I didn't
say that I'm saying it's no CR if he was
out of office part of what Congressman
Comer is saying we just got to
understand if Joe Biden was not in
office
eight weeks you get a million dollars
I'm not defending this I'm only saying
if he was out of office I wouldn't do
this but he has every legal right to do
it and if what you're saying is right
that they were paying him for something
he did in office Harold he should be
indicted to go to jail they just waited
until he left office and then paid the
family right through a third guy and uh
Kennedy these are all wouldn't you think
it affects someone's foreign policy if
they have if they have uh if they have
business dealings with the Chinese
government don't you think it affects
foreign policies and voters should know
about it before they cast a vote yeah I
think President Biden is in deep yogurt
and a number of Vats right now but I
think foreign policy may be the deepest
uh it appears that he and his family are
incredibly corrupt we it remains to be
seen whether or not they're truly
compromised but you know all of the all
of the tea leaves sort of point in that
direction and it's like I don't care if
it's a Yale Professor who is defending
the indefensible we know this is morally
wrong people should not be enriching
themselves on the back of their powerful
parents who may become the most powerful
person in the world I don't care
but I'm not defending this and Rob
Walker this is the guy who laundered the
money for the Bible
he worked in the Clinton administration
his wife worked for Jill Biden I mean
the cronies the cronies are corruption
and compromise the alliteration of sea
the The Depths to which this goes we're
using words I don't understand yes you
do you're a smart man former Congressman
you're a banker and you're you're a
decent human being and I want to say
something else China is a major player
in Biden's green energy policy and that
and a strategic partner also because
they're gonna we're gonna get the Cobalt
the lithium and everything else that we
need from China and the less but unless
we pump the less we drill the more we
need Jesse final thought Janine said
everything and one more thing to you
Harold who I love
just because you went to Yale doesn't
mean you're smart I didn't say you know
a lot of dummies that went to Yale
this experience
no one can say where the money went
right you know what that means it's a
bribe can I actually listen do you think
that President Trump's involved with Liv
golf is that appropriate do you think
that what the Saudis are bribing the
president and if president Trump comes
back to be president in office will you
will you argue with the argument we're
making that would mean that President
Trump could be compromised by llv weeks
but for what Donald Trump gets a
legitimate businessman who's worth
billions of dollars
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else